buonasera a tutti io ringrazio ied per
aver dato l'opportunità alla città di
milano di ospitare la riflessione di
questa sera
in realtà il titolo che avete scelto
giovani italiani lavorano anche alla
luce dei dati che purtroppo
quotidianamente ci inondano suona un po
come un ossimoro e credo che la volontà
degli organizzatori fosse proprio quella
di mettere in discussione questo sì
moreau noi sappiamo purtroppo che
l'italia è uno dei paesi europei con il
più alto tasso di disoccupazione
giovanile siamo ormai sopra il 40 per
cento su una media complessiva che è
oltre il 12 per cento
siamo però in una città che ha
performance migliori oggi la media in a
milano della disoccupazione giovanile è
intorno al 28 per cento in linea con gli
altri paesi europei di qualche giorno fa
sono i dati che ci raccontavano di quei
7 milioni di italiani giovani al di
sotto dei 34 anni che vivono ancora con
almeno un genitore insomma sono a casa o
sono tornati a casa 3 milioni virgola
due di questi proprio nella fascia tra i
24 e 25 ai 34 anni quindi diciamo nel
periodo post studio quello in cui
comincerebbe l'emancipazione dalla della
famiglia proprio grazie al lavoro ci
dicono ancora le statistiche ma su
questo poi alessandro rosina saprà
essere più preciso che ormai sono tra i
50.000 e 65.000 all'anno i giovani
italiani cosiddetti espatriati quelli
che cioè scelgono per scelta o per
obbligo di andare a vivere a lavorare
fuori dal proprio paese
dette così raccontati così questi numeri
ci raccontano proprio dell'ossimoro che
dicevo all'inizio però io credo che
valga la pena guardare meglio dentro e
oltre le statistiche
se questo è diciamo l'impatto bruto di
un numero che racconta un paese che fa
fatica a far emergere ea dare
possibilità alle sue giovani generazioni
c'è anche però io credo l'altro lato
della medaglia diceva albert camus non
si costruisce nulla di significativo se
non su nonostante tutto io credo che
siamo il paese in una fase diciamo
storica e le generazioni più prossimi
alle mie
lo testimoniano in cui quello che si
costruisce si costruisce veramente su
nonostante tutto ma che cosa c'è dietro
questi numeri
io credo che valga la pena anche per
indicare una strada se l'obiettivo della
serata organizzata dai ed è anche quello
di diciamo fissare un'agenda far
circolare delle idee di guardare cosa
c'è dietro i numeri io vedo una
generazione questo non lo vedo soltanto
io poi lo dicono anche i dati socio
demografici una generazione che ha
raggiunto il più alto tasso di scolo
realizzazione dal dopoguerra ad oggi
una generazione che ha le maggiori
competenze linguistiche rispetto a
quella a quelle che l'hanno preceduta
alle maggiori competenze digitali
informati che si nutre di quei soft
skills che oggi poi sono tanto richiesti
anche dalle aziende diciamo dal mercato
del lavoro
quindi una generazione che è piena di
potenzialità rispetto alle quali appunto
bisognerebbe guardare ed investire
quindi non definire soltanto anche da un
punto di vista diciamo delle analisi e
della costruzione delle azioni pubbliche
o private da fare
questa generazione su una negazione cioè
chi non ha il contratto chi non ha la
possibilità ma guardiamo per costruire
per progettare quello che hanno hanno
queste caratteristiche e io credo sia il
dato diciamo di partenza hanno la
caratteristica di essere
richiesti quando uno dei nostri giovani
nel mondo della ricerca o nel mondo
dell'impresa del privato fa un
application all'estero in università o
per le imprese e difficilmente viene
rifiutato quindi vuol dire che
nonostante tutto e nonostante la
possibilità e necessità di riformare il
sistema scolastico e universitario del
nostro paese la formazione che è stata
in partita e quindi l'investimento che
il paese ha fatto è un investimento che
risulta produttivo purtroppo spesso ne
se ne avvantaggiano diciamo di più i
paesi dove si si va a lavorare quindi
che non hanno fatto l'investimento alle
spalle ma questo è un dato qualche tempo
fa insieme all'associazione italians
abbiamo promosso come comune di milano
un sondaggio con l'idea di costruire poi
un intervento una politica interrogando
i giovani italiani espatriati e
soprattutto quelli che erano partiti da
milano
innanzitutto abbiamo scoperto che un
gran numero dei nostri giovani che oggi
sono all'estero sono partiti da milano
pur non essendo milanesi quindi la
nostra è una città ancora attrattiva per
le possibilità di primo impiego e per la
formazione è diventata una città di
attraversamento quando abbiamo chiesto
ai ragazzi quali sono state le ragioni
espulsive cioè cosa li ha spinti ad
andare via le risposte sono state varie
in cima alla classifica c'era il tema
della meritocrazia della possibilità di
essere riconosciuti e valorizzati per il
proprio talento
c'era anche il dato appunto degli
stipendi del livello sarà salariale o
dalla stabilità dei contratti ma in una
graduatoria sottostante un posto secondo
terzo rispetto al tema della
valorizzazione interessante però è stato
capire leggere dalle loro risposte che i
nostri giovani espatriati hanno voglia
di investire sul paese vogliono tornare
vogliono continuare a ragionare con con
chi è rimasto e questo credo che sia un
altro dato su cui ragionare per
costruire il futuro e per progettare un
legame tra chi è rimasto e chi è andato
via e fuori un altro elemento io credo
valga la pena richiamare ed è quello che
a che fare con i fenomeni emergenti cioè
se la domanda è dove dobbiamo guardare
per immaginare gli scenari e le
politiche
parlo da amministratore pubblico del
futuro io credo che dobbiamo guardare a
quello che succede nelle aree urbane ai
fenomeni emergenti delle città che in
larga misura interessano il protagonismo
delle giovani generazioni
qualche mese fa la città di milano ha
ospitato share italy la prima conferenza
convegno italiano sul tema della sharing
economy
io credo che questo sia un tema del
futuro che interessa molto le capacità e
le possibilità dei giovani non soltanto
come promotori diciamo i soggetti che
propongono offerte di sharing economy ma
anche come utilizzatori il dato della
crisi ci ha mostrato anche una nuova
propensione a fare impresa delle giovani
generazioni che questa sia diciamo una
costrizione a una propensione naturale
in questo momento è secondario ma
proprio qualche giorno fa coldiretti
pubblicava i dati sulle nuove imprese
nate nel 2013 ed indicava come i giovani
sotto i 35 anni fossero un terzo diciamo
dei giovani imprenditori
questa nuova
la propensione si trasforma anche
impossibilità da parte dei ragazzi
comunque le caratteristiche socio
demografiche e culturali che dicevo
prima di investire sul teso un tema che
oggi è molto discusso quello delle
startup oggi periodicamente il ministero
dello sviluppo economico aggiorna il
dato che forse possiamo mostrare che
alle mie spalle sulle cosiddette start
up innovative definite così da un
decreto dello scorso governo noi vediamo
come la maggioranza di queste diciamo
maggioranza relativa ovviamente siano
concentrate in lombardia e all'interno
della lombardia la città di milano
ovviamente fa la fa la parte del leone
quindi una capacità di generare imprese
innovative che si concentra soprattutto
nelle aree urbane e questo è un altro
punto che credo debba essere posto
all'attenzione dei decisori politici
cioè come incentivare e far sopravvivere
questa capacità diciamoci di fare
impresa e di scommettere sul futuro
un altro fenomeno emergente e quello del
coworking che interessa in larga parte
la città di milano milano appunto ospita
il maggior numero di spazi di coworking
abbiamo anche un infografica che si può
mostrare il comune di milano ha dato
vita ad un progetto specifico su questo
censendo e favorendo diciamo l'impiego
di giovani in questo è un nuovo modo di
organizzare il lavoro abbiamo un numero
importante di spazi nati dall iniziativa
privata 24 di questi hanno deciso di
accreditarsi in un elenco specifico che
il comune ha istituito collegato ad una
politica diciamo precisa quindi non
soltanto creazione d'impresa ma nuovo
modo di organizzare le relazioni
all'interno del lavoro quindi
organizzazione del lavoro che significa
condivisione di spazi ma anche
condivisione e di relazioni di mercato
cioè presentarsi al mercato come un
soggetto diciamo
unito integrato un ultimo tema perché il
mio tempo a disposizione è quasi finito
vedo che lo schermo brilla e il tema di
come rinnovare la tradizione
manifatturiera del nostro paese un paese
di piccole e medie imprese che ha fatto
diciamo di questa tradizione anche la
sua forza produttiva e competitiva con
la possibilità di innestarvi le nuove
tecnologie di cui i giovani sono
conoscitori e portatori e mi fa questo
elemento
mi fa nominare diciamo il movimento dei
makers un movimento che deve molto
all'italia pensiamo che i primi makers
digitali quelli che hanno inventato
arduino sono italiani oggi questo è un
tema molto discusso anche oltreoceano
chris anderson che introduceva diciamo
il video è uno dei guru di cianni di
questa nuova possibilità di coniugare
per l'italia e quindi in una
declinazione tutta italiana
una tradizione manifatturiera con una
possibilità di reinventare quella
tradizione in ottica diciamo del futuro
anche su questo la nostra città ha molto
da dire questo movimento è presente che
ci sono collegamenti tra chi si occupa
di questo e c'è anche una volontà da
parte delle istituzioni locali di
investire
io credo che questi elementi appunto il
tema della generazione di impresa
giovane con le nuove competenze digitali
informatiche relazionali vadano guardati
con attenzione anche nel momento in cui
si progetta alle politiche
oggi siamo alla vigilia diciamo di un
progetto molto importante che riguarderà
l'italia con un investimento di un
miliardo e mezzo di euro da parte
dell'unione europea parlo della garanzia
giovani una grande opportunità che non
va sprecata io credo che si debba
ragionare guardando a questa opportunità
coniugando le politiche di attivazione
più tradizionali con i fenomeni
emergenti e guardando alle città perché
le aree urbane
credo siano
pare che più possibilità danno alle
giovani generazioni e da cui più le
giovani generazioni diciamo possono
prendere siano comunque una possibilità
di sviluppo per il paese
guardo la nostra città penso a milano e
credo che se questo paese vedrà una
ripresa questa non potrà che passare
dalla dalla città di milano grazie anche
ai ragazzi e alle ragazze che vi vivono
e vi lavorano anche non essendo nati a
milano